so from being a dressmaker or would
tailor terminological to such
high-profile people to moving and doing
this kind of work in Guatemala how did
that happen I think these kinds of
changes its it looks really radical from
the outside in some ways but I think
changes that happen start somewhere
inside of you and you're here for many
years probably five I was the last five
years I was a tailor I had this stuff
going on back this sort of vague
dissatisfaction with the work and I
there was nothing wrong with the work
the work was great and the people are
wonderful and they are some of my
biggest supporters now but I just needed
I just needed something that was I think
it's something that would connect me to
I think I just really wanted to be
around people that weren't rich because
that's who I saw we my husband as a
painter his customers are all wealthy my
customers are all wealthy and we sort of
but they were not wealthy but we've sort
of walked in that part of society and it
just wasn't enough somehow and but I had
that sort of going on behind me and so
when the opportunity came to do this I
just visited the town of some my
cherished a ton which is where our work
is I kind of just fell in love with the
town and and that's what called me first
I would maybe I can find something that
will just bring me back here and that'll
that'll rule that'll make the parameters
of my work and then later when I heard
that they had never had a high school
that crystal crystallized sort of the
plan